today we're talking about careers ml ops
data transfer and communities i'm ryan
and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
the cloud computing industry is booming
and experts are in high demand
to help meet this demand and democratize
opportunity
google cloud is introducing its first
virtual certification journey learning
program
for underrepresented communities across
the united states
cloud career jumpstart the program is
free of charge
and includes technical and professional
skill development and resources to
provide readiness for certification
via the google cloud associate cloud
engineer exam
check out the blog for eligibility and
details
we recently published our ml ops
framework to help organizations come to
speed faster in this important domain
and to help ml practitioners translate
the framework into actionable steps
we release a blog post that highlights
some of the factors that influence where
to begin
based on our experience in working with
customers
overseeing a cloud migration is a tough
job but moving your actual data there
doesn't have to be
with the availability of our latest
transfer appliance for the us
eu and singapore regions we're providing
a simple secure
cost-effective and offline way to
transfer petabytes of data from data
centers and field locations
into google cloud check out the blog for
use cases and more information
helping developers be their best is core
to google cloud's mission
so we're excited to announce investment
in two new communities
the google cloud community and a
partnership with collectives on stack
overflow
both communities will serve to enhance
creativity foster greater collaboration
and contribute to the overall success of
our developer community and our value
customer base
they'll also provide a globally
connected source of information for
faster answers and recognition of
contributions
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud